look at mike tyson right now yeah he had
neck surgery we saw him after his neck
surgery i believe dude how about he's
[ __ ] doing uh poison frog drugs now
three times a day yeah what is that like
it's a hallucination i guess you take
the you lick the frog or the the
like the
serum from the frog yeah it takes you
another
yeah really no it's it's they're using
it for psilocybin too they're finding
amazing results with psilocybin for for
oh no he looks a toad
so do you just have that toad in your
house and you're just licking when you
walk by
that toes
i think it's a whole it's part of this
whole psychedelic thing for a depression
psychedelic is popping dude like you
know i've had buddies with people with
micro dose in it it really helps yeah i
have buddies with ptsd and uh
depression depression yeah they give a
micro dosing of shrooms yeah so it's a
really really bad apparently it really
does help
apparently tyson just walks by the stone
and licks him every now and then
really yeah the toad's like what the
[ __ ] he likes the toad i i i don't know
how i would do it will you kiss the tone
i would do it you would you do that [ __ ]
yeah it gets off of venom it has a venom
yeah you just got a little mushrooms and
toads like don't [ __ ] around because you
can touch the wrong poison arrow frog
and die well no tyson's not walking the
amazon rainforest just grabbing toads
and licking them where's that he's got
specific he's got something from like
actually america isn't it no
[Music]
sonoma
there's no [ __ ]
psychedelic frog colorado river toad all
knows
toads found in north that's not the one
they licked dude southwestern united
states no no it does that is the one
yeah that's the trendy toad huh isn't
that crazy that's the one that's out
here huh four to six times more powerful
than dmt now you and i did dmt and i was
lit give it up god is good was that when
you all was crying
i was ingested by licking the poisonous
feminine's back but it's now more
commonly consumed as a smokeable dust
form
oh so you got to go to uh zohan shamans
throughout mexico and southwestern so
like so texas new mexico
colorado that's southwestern right you
should go down there and pick up some
toast dude let's drive down there and
[ __ ]
kidnap some toads dude
let's traffic toads all right
we're already selling it let's just say
how long
he's like the bear from grateful dead no
fun toasting like his eyes change colors
it's like a dmt too called so fun toad
so fun has it already happened no oh
there you go oh this is just creating it
psychedelic toads all right colorado
river toad there it is dude we make one
with a mike tyson tattoo on his face
you're welcome whoever works now here's
my question i bet you the first time
they figured this out with somebody ate
one because they were hungry no i bet
somebody like oh hey you're probably
right someone's like i'm [ __ ]
starving and eight and then was like
short [ __ ] what it's a 20-minute trip
some say 20 minutes 20 minutes is
forever yeah because i was i was blitzed
and it was uh a minute dude i was like
how long was that he was like minute
thirty i'm like holy [ __ ] what's up gmt
five years we went summer special oh i
went somewhere so special i'll do it
i'll do that toad thing in a heartbeat
i'll do the toad thing in the right
corner i'll do trt toad stuff hair
transplant i'm gonna be [ __ ] awesome
do you give me a different get my teeth
whiten dude i get but where do we buy
these toads from i think the best thing
is we vlog it on thick boy and we go
down to new mexico and capture these
frogs i'll do it
but i wonder how crazy is down there i
bet it's pretty competitive that's
that's why well i bet marcus i
guarantees has a has a connection we
just got to get a good connection i
actually have a very good connection
through these toasts
yeah i got a healthy guy with butter i
got a rich as [ __ ] dude who's a friend
who's
all about psychedelics like he's got
stupid money and they'd say there's that
community it's a risk i have a billion
dollars now what do i do like toads
they're all like i want to get closer to
god yeah
yeah why are celebrities smoking too oh
they smoke it no i just want to smoke it
they so they dry they dry the venom it
becomes a dust and then we smoke it the
wheat that's how we we did dmt yeah we
did smoke it like crack yeah but i'll
lick it too and the dmt trip was what a
minute a minute thirty minute thirty but
it felt like forever wow tell me call
this
desert colorado river toad shout out to
colorado i think she does speak out and
be found around store in desert in cal
in california dude that's right up the
street but this isn't back our toad i
need that valley toad